Oh
I think that there will always be
small-scale scandals there will always
be plagiarist there will always be
people who didn't make the phone call
that they claim to have made but the
chronic repeated abuse that Jayson Blair
was engaged in I don't think it happened
at a newspaper that has a public editor
or an ombudsman yes there was a phone
number published in the newspaper in The
Times every day for people to call if
they had something that they objected to
and when I got there I thought I'd try
out the system well it's a mailbox full
nobody had been paying attention to it
if you have somebody whose job is
specifically to respond to readers who
are complaining or who are pointing out
error or pointing out misbehavior in the
part of reporters it's very hard I can't
imagine that it would not be caught
after the second or third time because
you know somebody's reading that now
somebody's paying attention to it
my biggest concern about the digital
technology as it's coming to the news
world is anonymity of writers whether
that's the person who's you know writing
a blog or who's commenting on a sign on
a signed blog we don't know who those
people are and one thing and this is not
an ethical issue this is a question of
civility and taste I mean it allows
cowards to hide behind that that scrim
while they have the freedom to say
really awful and disgusting things and I
can't stand that it's very upsetting to
me but beyond that there have been a few
instances where that person who's been
commenting on this web site of that web
site in fact as a principal in the story
has in fact a a figure who has a self
interest but is hiding that self
interest I would really be delighted to
see the the websites of the world just
suddenly declare put on your real name
er we don't care what you have to say
and in fact I don't care what you or you
shouldn't care what I have to say if I'm
not willing to put my name behind it
I think that the the the peak years for
for quality journalism in this country
1970s and early 1980s
if you go back before then I mean pick
up a copy the New York Times in 1965
some day it was unbelievably dull it was
official ease if the there were a new
Peruvian ambassador appointed there was
in the paper the shipping news that just
the sort of the kind of the deadly
required drone of news in those days was
was really pretty awful the paper got
much much better after that as did all
American journalism and I think the
Watergate obviously had a great deal to
do with Watergate and also the magazine
writers of the sixties people like like
Gay Talese and David Halberstam both
came out of the times but then moved to
other arenas to be able to do more than
simply Chronicle they could write they
did more than coming together that and
the great victory for journalism that
was Watergate created a I think in the
70s that attracted better people to the
industry it was a more exciting thing to
do and they did and people did their
greatest work then and the standards
were very very high as we get into the
90s and we began to have an economic
trouble beginning to show up you know
Time magazine where I worked for quite a
while in nineteen ninety ninety had
eight full-time critics on staff doing
different things today I think there's
one full-time critic and that's not that
criticism is the most important thing in
the world but I use it as an indication
of how things have shrunk back because
of the economic problems